morning John this is what a budding and
wearing to your movie premiere I don't
know if it too much is it not enough I
don't know
coming all the way from Montana show
those New York people a thing or two
about how people should dress you know
dead cow on them check out the tie if he
owes colors tie Johnny he have
officially received over 100,000
responses to the 2014 nerdfighter
essence this is even more exciting
because over half of the 140,000 that
responded last year didn't respond this
year I don't know what those people were
doing there's a hundred thousand of them
maybe they figured they'd do one sense
especially wait four years or so before
I do another one right but it's not
because people weren't around last year
because 75% of respondents have been
watching since before 2013 that's a lot
of longtime nerdfighters other
interesting data from the survey a
hundred percent of people said that my
new album incongruent is a masterful
work of genius it was the only option I
gave them but still usually a lot of
people didn't even know that I have a
new album so I have a new album in fact
there are a number of things that we do
that people didn't know anything about
14 percent of people don't know about
the Mental Floss channel where we're
constantly spewing interesting facts
about the world thirty percent of people
don't know that we've spun off scishow
into a second scishow channel so this
scishow and scishow space 33 percent of
people don't know about our year-old
youtube sex education and information
show sexplanations with dr. lindsey doe
50% of people don't know about how to
adult our guide to suddenly becoming an
adult and oh god oh god 64 percent of
people don't know about our new show
animal wonders but the number one most
underground super indie nobody knows
about a thing that's part of vow of our
enterprises is the warehouse the
warehouse is a show that is produced out
of the dftba records warehouse by
Matthew Gaydos who is the head of
customer service at dftba records
actually watched him do a show at Sean
Kelly's last night in Missoula he is a
rock star
somewhat difficult for me to believe is
that 40% of people don't know about
subbable I just feel like everybody
knows about it because it's been so
successful for helping us fund our shows
like scishow and crash course and
sexplanations would all not exist
anymore if it weren't for subbable for
those 40% of people who don't know
subbable is our voluntary subscription
platform you can go and subscribe to any
of a number of projects and when you
subscribe you can choose
out to pay per month that can be $0 it
could be five or ten a million dollars a
month nobody's done that yet and that
helps those shows exist for everybody
including people can't pay for them
speaking of people who can't pay for
them the counts of the questions about
subbable and dftba in my album there are
lots of people saying I don't have money
if you're really bad that having bought
your things that are done money don't
feel bad about that ever that is the
last thing I want is for you to spend
money when it will make you less
financially secure you buy something
from us and it's making you less
financially secure I am NOT happy don't
do that no and really astonishingly one
more people have read JK Rowling books
than have read John Green books but only
very slightly and something like 92% of
you have read The Fault in Our Stars
which is a lot so I'm assuming that all
of those people will be interested in
going to the night before our stars it's
an event that's happening all over
America not outside America sorry
not America people also not in
everywhere in America like it's not
happening here in Missoula for example
the screening of the movie the day
before it comes out on June 5th 5:30
Eastern 8:30 Pacific I think and then
after the movie there's going to be a
live stream of questions and interviews
and music with John Green
brother the gun on the side of this
camera NAT Wolff Ansel Elgort shailene
woodley Josh Boone the director other
people it's gonna be cool you check it
out if you can sorry very sorry to all
the people who can't John
congratulations coming to your premiere
gonna get on a plane tomorrow and come
see you looking forward to it I'll see
you then though I have to say Hank your
video about how to field-strip a fusion
reactor or realign the power transfer
tunnel in a warp coil generator is
lacking in even the most rudimentary
understanding of matter antimatter
principles